Hello, everyone! Welcome to the Langfocus channel.
This is just a quick mini-video to answer
a frequently asked question that I get on my channel,
and that is: "What is a lingua franca?"
"Lingua franca" is a phrase
that I use a lot on the channel.
A lingua franca is a language that is used
for communication between people
who speak different native languages.
Here are a couple of example situations
of when a lingua franca is necessary.
For example, there are many languages spoken
in a particular area or amongst different ethnic groups,
and they need a language
to communicate with one another.
Another example: there is trade between
two different countries that have no common language.
Example three: at a professional conference for experts
from different countries who have different native languages.
On a global scale, the current largest
lingua franca is English,
but there are other various lingua francas
on a regional level and on a national level.
An example of a regional lingua franca
is the French language in Africa.
There are a lot of different languages spoken in Africa,
and in a large portion of the continent, they use French
as their language of communication,
as their lingua franca.
An example of a national lingua franca is, in Pakistan,
where there are various different languages spoken,
but Urdu, the national language, is used
as the lingua franca between those different goups.
Another similar situation is in Philippines,
where they have two lingua francas, kind of,
or they mix the two lingua francas sometimes.
They have Tagalog and English,
and those are used as the lingua francas
between people from different regions of the country.
Sometimes, there are both national lingua francas
and more local lingua francas within a country.
So, if we take the example of Philippines,
there is a region where Ilocano is the main language.
So, if someone from the Ilocano-speaking region meets
someone from, for example, the Bisaya-speaking region,
they'll probably use the national lingua franca,
which is Tagalog or English, or use both of them.
But if that same person meets someone from the
Ilocano-speaking region who speaks a different language,
like a minority language, then they'll probably use
that local language, Ilocano, as the lingua franca.
Because just in that one region,
there are various languages spoken,
so the lingua franca you use depends on who
you're speaking to, so you're sort of leveling up.
If you speak to someone in your region, you can
understand them, use that regional lingua franca.
If you speak to someone from a different region,
use the national lingua franca.
So it sounds all kind of complicated,
but basically it means : speak the language that helps
you communicate with that person the best.
Why do we say "lingua franca"?
The term "lingua franca" itself comes from the name
of a language that was spoken in this way
in the Mediterranean region for hundreds of years.
It was kind of a creole Romance language (*Actually,
PIDGIN not creole*)  that had a lot of vocabulary from
different Mediterranean languages mixed into it.
One English source from 1632 referred
to this language as "Bastard Spanish."
So, to wrap up and clarify, a lingua franca is
a language that is used for communication
between the speakers of different native languages.
I hope that clarifies things.
Thank you for watching. Have a nice day.